the fast festival culminates on May 7th
with fast light which will be an event
that illuminates all of mi t--'s campus
and waterfront there are series of
installations by the faculty in the
department of architecture there will
also be a series of pavilions that are
open to the public they are doing a kind
of range of projects from photovoltaic
soft rockers which multiple people can
sit on and absorb energy and light up in
the evenings two collaborations between
architects and performance artists or
architects and video artists where the
design of the pavilion is specific to
the work of art being featured in the
pavilion several art installations will
be in the river and work off the
reflection of the water etc at nighttime
these installations will be interactive
so they'll invite the public into them
to actually contribute to the
choreography of the light we also wanted
to involve the amazing MIT students and
so we had an open competition this was
open to schools across campus we had
proposals that were all incredibly
fascinating to the point where we didn't
know actually if the proposal came from
an artist and architect a biologist or a
physics major one student project is
called the ice wall which consists of
these kind of large ice cubes built that
will build a kind of wall and embedded
in these cubes are seeds that when they
melt they'll you know become flowerbeds
in the spring and then there's a time
capsule video piece by another student
from the Media Lab and then there are
larger environmentally scaled
installations by students like a string
tunnel on campus that will just take a
kind of mundane everyday space at MIT
and for a couple of weeks transform it
into
a special environment the amazing thing
about the MIT students is that they are
completely fearless they have no
boundaries their interdisciplinary by
nature they benefit so much from MIT as
an institute by being able to take
classes across all of the schools and I
think this really is reflected in the
projects that they are going to be doing
for the fast festival in that they are
incredibly creative and innovative and
they have a certain quality of magic and
optimism about technology the arts and
the future
you